[Music]
it's Thursday and you know what that
means
everyone loves
live babes
[Applause]
[Laughter]
hey look at that Anthony bones look at
that it's uh we like that intro he's
doing the heavy lifting we'll eventually
get back to songs yeah it's not going to
be like this forever no we have a
special guest in the hey babe Studios
for the very first time you may know him
from my world I've speak about him a lot
we had a big weekend this weekend that
we're going to talk all about Sal and I
had a great time and we thought it would
be nice to bring in the man whose balls
I came from Tampa Tony Tony DeStefano
[Laughter]
it 8.95 shoes
my black socks black pants I'm good slay
King I love a king but also uh does he
not give you gifts like does he give you
like you know any you could you could
get him in a nice fit I get him and I I
give him New Balances but he the problem
you've had to glow up I've had to go up
the problem is with my father is he
needs his sneaker sizes in whatever
number it is size wide so when he goes
in there he'll say I need a size 12 wide
and a lot of times these these
fashionable sneakers everywhere they
don't have it in a white no so my dad
needs it a white and typically doesn't
like to tie shoelaces so what's he's
rocking right now is the slip-on
Skechers he doesn't want to get the
hassle of the lace as he gets older he
said he's done with you can't bend that
far down yeah well what I do what I am
picking up here is you're all about
comfortability that's right and honestly
I feel that shift happening in my own
life yeah where I just don't care I want
to drape myself in velvet flip-flops and
I want to walk around like that that's
it the biggest weekend of my career
career-wise we did radio station Musical
and theater at Madison Square Garden and
it was amazing both show sold out thank
you to the fans that came Sal was the
surprise guest and dropped in and did a
beautiful guest spot at the theater at
Madison Square Garden and annihilated
and ended the show reading a very angry
email from Joe DeRosa or from one of Joe
deroza's you know private accounts but
I'm bringing that up to say
my father great you know my biggest
shows of my life and my father wore this
exact outfit both nights so that's but
that's but now you know when you're at a
level where you're saying I don't care
but is that is that not the ultimate in
what cool is yes being unapologetically
yourself no matter when there's
pressures to not be that's right that
jacket no look yeah right that jacket
you're wearing which you said was 9.95
from the rack at CVS it's next to the
toilet paper on the CVS on Manor Road on
Staten Island that jacket yes that's
that is a fit right it is that jacket is
a jacket that we would wear and be like
that's official it just goes to show you
all the Couture all the extra money
spent on the designer stuff that small
children are making across the globe
yeah you could buy stuff that small
that is more reasonable exactly um I
like I like the color I love I would
have never known that was you could have
told me that was a 70 jacket
my wife would kill me go to the CVS on
Manor Road get get a booster and get a
jacket from Staten Island
um I got all the boosters by the way yes
the guys boost it you're boosted up
you're boosted heavy you're 5G that's it
I'm boosting now let me ask you dad what
did you think about this this weekend's
experience we have a picture up right
now of me holding my daughter Violet who
as I was walking across the stage I
swear to God no one I can't prove this
maybe if Pimp's audio picked it up but
literally this picture is being taken I
saw a pimp out of the corner of my
walking on the stage and moments before
after this picture she said oh my [__] I
knew I swear to God
I said is it going to be on my [__] oh
my God it wasn't for a little while and
then you came back have you heard Violet
say oh my [__] dad in the house yes I
have I thought you were talking about me
going to the bathroom
four weeks no dookie no what's what's
your what's what's the latest and
greatest with that yeah the latest and
greatest dad is still no dookie you
haven't when's the last time
no dookie is the title of the episode
obviously
two weeks no dookie and is that is that
common is this a record or have you been
in the area of two weeks no dookie
before I've been in that area
my doctor said it's normal oh so you
flirt with two weeks no dookie yeah on a
regular basis he didn't take one crap at
all in the summer of 21.
basically zero he maybe took one or two
the entire episode
no one or two craps the entire summer of
21. one or two craps easily maybe we but
where is Food he blames me I blame him
because when I was in his house I fell I
fell off the off the bench hit my back
he said no there's nothing wrong to
everybody pick me up threw me in the
water you never said you never crank it
out never duked again well I I do every
now and then but you think that no Duke
is because of when you fell and hurt
your back hit my back yep and how does
that how does that transpire into how
does that manifest itself as no dude
that's when that that's where how I
pinpointed it I was doing well until
it was your assessment it's my
assessment okay now what happens when
you finally do do it is do is it a
relief what do like is it a lot it's a
lot it's like the Super Bowl it's a
Super Bowl is there a half time
you know what you need he needs uh uh uh
seed DSO one symbiotic he does he needs
well if they if they would start um they
would start advertising again we could
get you on it then we can get them on a
program and we can document it now what
happened he's the new face of it yes did
you what did you think about my shows
this weekend I I can't wait to get into
okay I can't wait but I can't have this
hanging over my head okay where does the
food go the two weeks worth of food go
that you've been eating
if it's not coming out well like if I
put on a table that all the food you ate
for the last two weeks
and then I say I'm putting that in you
and it's not coming out of you how does
that how does that how is that possible
how does that work well I don't I don't
eat it I don't eat a lot anymore it's
just gonna appear yeah yeah your magic
you actually have a surprise guest out
of them yeah we have a surprise guest
out because we've said you know you
haven't taken a [__] in two weeks and we
wanted to make you [__] your pants so we
brought in Rob Eiler the kid from The
Sopranos
he's quit acting he's moved to Austin
that's his new life now what do you
think of that what do you think of his
choices uh very good yeah what do you
like the choices I'm very comfortable
with the choices I like that I like a
kid like I like a guy
and just said you know what I'm gonna do
what the hell I want to do I appreciate
that I like that playing poker not
acting living in Austin good for you
dude because I want to quit comedy every
day and I'm I'm too scared because I I
don't know if he has health insurance
and have to pay for his bowel movements
with him right now that he's uppity and
you know he's pretty opening now so
yeah Money Changes people right exactly
ah dude what are you talking about Tampa
Tony just yeah I got the sweatshirt for
free shout out busting with the boys
if this is if this was like three years
ago I would have been scheduled properly
but now he's a big shot it's like yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
do you need a ride to the airport
tomorrow by the way because Rob is going
there
wow great hat Rob great hat I told you
corduroy hat beautiful
thank you yeah I was uh the other day
Jamie Lynn was in town for a day and we
did uh Jim and Sam and we walked out of
there and I saw the MLB store and I'm
like man I'm a big hat guy and I go in
and I see this I see it I try on a bunch
of hats this hat fit me better than any
hat I've ever had but it's San Diego and
then the next the one next to it is
Boston Red Sox there's no way I'm ever
wearing that and then a Mets hat and the
guy goes yeah we're out of everything
else this is all we have I I looked like
it was like Fight Club when he's just
talking to himself the whole like I
walked to the door of the store I was
like no yeah but you gotta get the
[__] house
and I'm like fully fighting with myself
like you're not gonna wear it in San
Diego I'm like but that it fits you
better than anything's ever fit you in
your life what are you gonna do and the
guy's like dude it's a hat like you want
it or not I'm like this is I've never
worn a hat that's not a Yankee hat dude
it looks awesome as soon as I saw it I
said that's a hat and also with the mind
of like being around people with bus
balls I'm like suck dick
but Boston and Mets I can never yeah I
could I could never yeah it's tough it's
tough where were you from originally
Manhattan New York City my whole life
there you go yeah yeah New York City
native and actually so is my dad from
Manhattan look at that wow where'd you
grow up 118th Street between second and
third okay 92nd and second oh so there
you go wow yeah
you want to do a pause together sure we
should do a pause
we probably know the same people yeah
118 isn't that up by the it's Harlem
right oh I thought it was Spanish
Spanish home yes basically but back then
it was mostly Italians yeah yeah well if
you go right it's all Spanish black you
go the other way to a white boy so there
was always a there's always a clash
always a clash also if you're from New
York City you're like it's it's [__]
Harlem Uptown Midtown downtown all this
like neighborhood [__] it's all like
it's also people could sell real estate
[Laughter]
There's real small ones yeah where you
from babe me
uh Ridgewood Ridgewood Ridgewood Queens
Ridgewood Queens Brooklyn I like it it's
on the board I really have a like a love
affair with Queens after meeting all
your boys you're going out so Forest
Hills it's really nice out there Queen's
like I think Queens uh Hip-Hop Hip-Hop
they like you too my boys that that
shout out my boy Chris good stuff man
good tomorrow great time my dad works at
Queen Center Mall does he right always
my whole life yeah yeah he's always
working Queens Center Mall yeah yeah
that's awesome huh he probably knows
your mother oh my mother's in Queens
Center Mall all day every day
set them up
can you imagine this is how we're Step
Brothers
did you guys just become best friends
wow Queen sent them all you've ever been
to the Queen Center Mall South I don't
believe so Queen Center mall it's like
to start an animal but in Queens all
right is it is it
well we have our mole was not ever good
growing up compared to like the Jersey
malls but then they did a big overhaul
but I haven't been to it in 10 years but
now it's different it was just a shitty
mall or is it like is it considered it
was shitty now it's good but like
growing up in New York City even at like
I'm 38 now I still think malls are cool
because I've only going up till 20 I
only saw them in the Google The
Manhattan yeah yeah so I'd see it in
movies are dope like that's where [__]
goes down that's a hike for your dad
from Manhattan and Queen Center mall but
he did it well yeah well he moved to
Queens and was working there and yeah
divorced yeah well they were my parents
had me when they were like 17 18 like
barely even wow you know like they were
kids they weren't even like I don't even
know if they were dating or what they
just had you but so but but your dad was
in your life
divorced parents he lived on Staten
Island I lived in Queens this guy never
missed a baseball practice never missed
the baseball practice again nothing my
dad missed some stuff
I wasn't allowed he nervous Nelly over
here
that also might be the title of the
party
no dude uh no dookie for two weeks my
dad barely shits what was the first one
called I used to happen two week no
dookie or uppity
Rob just said he used to have that issue
too I was addicted to Percocets for a
long time okay
[Laughter]
okay give me one I took it
and the garbage you didn't you faked it
I faked it yeah I yeah I mean Percocet
they'll clock you up yeah no perks
though for you lately no I've been over
10 years now wow good boy yeah and I'm
not as fun as I used to I used to be a
lot
yeah but I'm pretty miserable yeah and
it's like yeah you came to the right
places yeah people are like oh it's
raining you okay like it's always
raining
and it's always
Miss Karen's divorced when I was four
and I swear to God I will have a
one-hour conversation with myself about
a hat without a dick yeah but I do agree
you gotta go don't worry about the team
as long as it's not the Red Sox I feel
like I was like transitioning yeah you
know what I mean like what how do you
you get a pass it's like a sharp hat if
it's not you're I I think I'm under the
impression if it's not your actual
number one adversary or whatever you're
fine you can do it I have I have
baseball jerseys the batting practice
jerseys from every team in the major
leagues besides the Red Sox I will never
get the Red Sox but any other team Mets
include whoever I think you can rock it
it's no problem but you just can't get
whatever your team's rival is yeah but
also the Mets the Mets is tough you
don't like the Mets I just said that
when I was younger but I've come around
a little bit but even no I but even I I
like like if I'm you know if the Yankees
are out I'll root for the mission but
still putting on like the orange and
blue yeah it's just I know you need
something inside you won't feel
comfortable I had to do it I had to do
it because we filmed that [__] at a city
field and so I put on the uniform I put
on the hat they made me my own Jersey so
I put it on and I did I it felt like
completely foreign to me to be in those
colors right but it was cool as a
pinstripe felt like a throwback so I
just didn't want to wear Nick stuff the
Nicks are orange
it's different though I guess but the
Knicks are orange the Mets feel like a
minor league team tonight I mean like it
just has that Vibe like even like the
cut it just feels like right they're the
scrappy ones and where the you know the
yeah yeah also my dad's a Met fan you
know he talked to he wasn't there so
yeah the Mets represent that yeah yeah
do you think do you are you in line do
you think maybe you could date Taylor
Swift
oh I couldn't dude even when I was like
out drinking all the time I was always
the civilian I I go for civilians you
know you don't go like these guys it's a
it's like I need a box I mean it's one
yeah it's just too much it's too it's
already a lot dating yeah then you throw
in like oh yeah well my security get the
[__] no no no no no look at this she
left uh the Chiefs game a couple of days
ago uh yes or what is today Tuesday on
Sunday in uh in a popcorn machine did
you see this wait she's in that popcorn
she didn't want pictures
you're telling me so do they know that's
her in there and she's just doing it
because she doesn't want to see them or
she trying to be sneaky
okay all those people are on those
barriers and the person filming the
popcorn card come by so they know she's
in it at this point that's so weird so
is there anything with her show is it is
it just because she's having fun with it
or is it a security measure
that she has to go travel around her pop
doesn't want him he doesn't want to be
funny my pop my point is why popcorn
machine why not just go in a coffin or
you know like a a a
you know a bin according to the your dad
the direction you're headed you're gonna
be in a popcorn machine another time
seriously you know you're all pretty
nervous Nelly
thank you
[Laughter]
just saying just saying swifties yeah
it's interesting so she's she's now
dating Travis Kelsey is that I saw her
in this baby you smell like butter
she's now dead she's now dating Travis
Kelsey and here's what um here's what
the internet the reason why oh hold on
my food delivery
hello
yeah can you can you bring it up to the
sixth floor and leave it
okay yeah you could just leave it at
least you just leave it there just leave
it on that table I'll come get it
yes sir
okay
oh you got away from me
just leave it
yeah you could just leave it
all right tip tomorrow yeah I already
tipped on on the app
oh you hung up
to the mail okay here we go what the
internet is saying about Travis Kelsey
and Taylor Swift is uh guys beam dream
powder uh I got I have that on my
kitchen counter right now I started
using it last year when Bean became a
sponsor for the show I love it uh a
couple things do you know poor sleep can
cause weight gain uh poor mental health
lower productivity because it absolutely
can sleeping less than six to seven
hours a night is linked to reducing the
white blood cell count I don't need to
tell you that sleep is important uh this
stuff is delicious it's like hot cocoa
and it tastes like hot cocoa and I drink
it and I have the best night's sleep
that I can possibly have
um nothing's worse than when I'm on the
road and I have to sleep or I have to
sleep the next morning and for some
reason that night I can't fall asleep
this is uh how I combat it I really like
it uh find out why Forbes and New York
Times are all talking about beam and why
he's trusted by the world's top athletes
and business professionals and
podcasters I guess
uh if you want to try beam's
best-selling dream powder guys get up to
40 percent off for a limited time when
you go to shopbeam.com hey babe and use
the code hey babe at checkout that's
shop beam b e a m.com slash hey babe and
then use the code hey babe for up to 40
off guys we have a great uh offer with
doordash here get 50 off your first
doordash order up to twenty dollar value
when you use code hey babe marked at
checkout limited time offer terms apply
that's hey babemart m-a-r-t at checkout
you want even more value you can save on
all your grocery and restaurant
favorites with a zero dollar delivery
fee on all eligible orders with a dash
pass membership now yeah I'll tell you
what I love doordash I talked about it
on here before and I use it I literally
use it weekly because I don't cook and
it enables me to get food and dinner or
lunch whatever from places that don't
deliver uh you know and so that's never
happened before and then also on the
road I use doordash because if the hotel
doesn't have you know room service this
is amazing and uh I can get anything I
want it's actually better than room
service so I love it but one thing I
didn't do was use it for groceries and I
started to do that now and I realized
damn I don't have to go to the grocery
store I can get this stuff within like
an hour which is ridiculous I can make
substitutions if I pick something that I
want to change before the order is is
done it's just so convenient they drop
it off at your door it's done through
the app a lot of times like I'll have a
last minute thing I don't realize I'll
make I'll be making like waffles and I
realize I don't have syrup it's like all
right I'll hold off I'll order this
it'll be here in 15 minutes and my whole
waffle morning that I was hoping for
isn't screwed get 50 off your first
doordash order up to 20 value when you
use code hey babe Mart a check check out
limited time offer terms apply right
scroll a second okay Bim so guys that's
fifty five oh percent off up to twenty
dollars on your first order through
doordash when you enter the code hey
babe Mart one more time don't forget
that's code hey babe Mart for 50 off
your first order up to twenty dollars
when you try doordash so what the
internet is saying about Travis Kelsey
and Taylor Swift is uh here's what
here's what they're saying you should be
talking about how Taylor Swift was a
gift to Travis Kelsey from Pfizer for
selling out and pushing the facts
don't you don't see the correlation that
this new couple pops up as soon as his
new advertisement for the coveted
vaccine is launched it's very simple his
status gets elevated to new levels he
becomes even more wealthy than he was
and he gets a taste of Taylor's box
meanwhile a million bucks
yes meanwhile millions of mindless
followers look up Travis Kelsey and see
that he's also Pro vaccine so now
they're okay with the Taylor sacrificed
her body they Illuminati years ago so
giving it up to Kelsey nothing oh yeah
he's also publicly stated for years that
he's into black girls so now all of a
sudden he likes the whitest girl in
America
okay when did you post that uh yes yeah
I posted that uh you know yeah that um
ridiculous that everyone knows it now
yeah she's just in that box she's doing
bits yeah I mean like like it's so weird
there's like mops on top of that it's a
bit it is a bit it's got to be but
because why can't she just walk with
security from there to there and this
screaming
screaming kind of
it just it just it makes it like it's it
makes it the thing that it doesn't have
to be well then again I don't know what
her life is like right she's clearly
right now she's the most famous person
on the planet she doesn't need to be in
there who is the most famous person on
the planet for real like it may be hard
times you think Tom Cruise I think
because he's just a different but I
guess but young people don't know him so
no it depends
could be as much as any other president
really right but I'm saying like if you
went around yeah Trump would be more
famous than Barack right right yeah talk
about like the the the the most
recognized so they're saying Cristiano
Ronaldo is the most famous person in the
world because I was thinking about this
the other day I wouldn't know he was
sitting right here me neither me neither
yeah but we everybody does know Taylor
Swift I bet you I bet you
Taylor Swift like it was MJ I would yeah
it was it was Michael Jackson yeah yeah
that's that's it was yeah could it be
Madonna
I don't think so not now no right I mean
she's up there but I'm just saying when
we're talking about that top like oh oh
one percent right yeah the rock is okay
I guess yeah it's Kardashian she's got
like oh they're saying Taylor Swift is
eight Selena Gomez I would not put up
Selena Gomez Beyonce Warren Buffett I
don't know I don't know if people know
what he looks like Tom Cruise he's in
there as couples it's probably Jay-Z and
Beyonce right is there like a more
famous couple right are they probably
are they probably are the most famous
couple Jay-Z and Beyonce would have to
say
uh Rich yeah Rich Swanson Bonnie
McFarland
should be on that yeah but he's always
got a new girlfriend that's what I'm
saying
yeah
oh Megan Megan Markle and Prince Harry
are up there if I if I walked into a
restaurant Prince Harry was saying no I
would have no idea it was him like just
because he he looks like a lot of dudes
yeah you know what I mean like unless
somebody told me
yeah that that's like um oh yeah John
Krasinski and Emily Blunt but again I
don't know that they're the this is like
in America talking Jay-Z and Beyonce
JJ and Beyonce's the answer Kanye and
Kim were one at that time yeah that's
like inarguable what's this guy Tom
Cruise is so famous there's not even
like Paparazzi shots of him you know
what I mean because he just control he's
like no we're not no you know we're not
doing it I always wonder how someone at
that caliber that's the guy who's saying
look at how he comes into Stage we
seriously have to come on to stage one
day like this
way to God so that's what we're doing
my God
it looks like CGI you know that get some
people going could you imagine him
breaking his leg wait look they weren't
cheering before
and then they literally just it was like
look at this crowd I kind of want to see
this guy that looks like like literally
like like limp biscuits
I heard he does Gangnam Style like five
or six times in a row like he just
constantly it's his opener and his
clothes
foreign
[Laughter]
style right there or does he have like
now like a discography that we don't
know about
as a it's the 11th most viewed video on
YouTube 4.9 billion views is that more
than salsa windfall
um uh
yeah I think he only has I think that's
his song though 60 yeah
well yeah because because you know oh is
he invested in K-pop yeah what happened
to him oh something happened to him no
no
what happened to him after the Gangnam
Style
except those cookies
can you read that because I don't have
my glasses okay this article is part of
Yahoo's online
okay so Gangnam style 2012 Korean pop
sensation Psy
um Gangnam Style and then Park Jay sang
now 43 have been expected to follow his
Father's Footsteps as an executive at
his Semiconductor Company
um but fell in love with electronic
music when he went to the USA could you
imagine dude by the way real quick
vaccine
you never auditioned for sopranos and
instead you filed your Father's
Footsteps working at the Queen Center
Mall
I'd just be staring at the roof right
now
is it lunchtime yet my high school
classmate killed himself and the Queen
Center Mall jumped off the fourth uh
floor oh yeah my dad he was there for
that my dad all of them yeah yeah yeah
yeah it happens a lot yeah not a lot but
it's happened yeah people want to do it
yeah my friend yeah yeah what yeah it's
a thing there they got there I was close
when I couldn't find the Yankee hat yeah
um is there a is there something there
that looks like it's super high why why
there it's like five levels or something
oh it is
doing indoors during oh oh yeah yeah
yeah people generally get suicidal
because I know they do it off of that
that's crazy they have to close that
down yeah they just had to close it down
at the Hudson yards because people
really yeah people because it looks like
a big one is off of it
um I I honestly
honestly that's that's that's that's oh
man that's rough because you're putting
that on everybody in that mall kids that
witness that like some who my friend who
did it he he would sleep over my house
all the time when we were in high school
and I remember in high school he had
like he had problems like psychological
issues right but we were kids we didn't
know anything uh so I'm just drilling oh
but you don't pick it up on the audio
though do you
know whatever it's free on YouTube
that would ever be a fight
what are you gonna do what do you say
who are you texting your assistant see
if she got my food
um I uh I yes
so so this my my friend you sleep over
my house right and he was a great
basketball player and we would sleep
over and I remember one day where my
house where my mom still lives it was my
room and her room shared a wall like my
bedroom and my mom's bedroom shared a
wall so I he got up in the middle of the
night one night he was just like pacing
back and forth down the hallway and he
was like this these little green men
everywhere like there's these little
green men everywhere and my mom woke up
and was like honey go back to sleep like
there's no green man it's fine he goes
I'm telling they're everywhere it's
great and we were like we were laughing
I was like this kid's an idiot like we
were making fun of them like whatever we
were kids we didn't know and then went
in and out of uh you know uh uh uh
psychiatric ward when we were in our 20s
and then one day he killed himself and
the person at the Queen Center mall I
remember I read it in the Queen's Ledger
they said kid killed himself you know
his name whatever and like he was
reported to saying there was Little
Green Men everywhere right before he
jumped and I was like holy [__] oh my
God yeah so uh can you make that funny
a thing man with the I've heard that
more that people kill themselves at the
Queen Center mall and then they kill
themselves they throw themselves off the
Golden Gate Bridge too yeah that's like
the whole documentary is that him you
can't make this stuff up
now they're hammering dude I say we're
outside of our wall I say we just plowed
through all right this is this is the
construction episode we got we got Rob
Eiler here we got tamper Tony here we
got homeless pin past no microphone
um we're gonna make Rob do [__]
Percocets again with all this
I I well listen before you walked in we
heard that he didn't he he had recently
he hasn't you said dookied in uh two
weeks two weeks and I said if you took
all the food that you ate all those two
weeks and put it on this table like how
is it feasible where is it going if it
goes in you that whole food and it
doesn't come out of you what's happening
uh nothing I mean I try to go I think I
have to go but nothing I guess I could
get gas well what I mean where is the
actual food that you should it doesn't
eat that much anymore oh I know you've
been intermitting faster he's on the
fasting app my dad's lost over 50 pounds
is it 10.
congratulations thank you imagine if he
was [__] how much oh my God
oh my God
okay you think she takes any enhancing
drugs or anything no no that's natural
she's just she's she's uh she's keto
I've never seen anyone like that in my
entire life is that a guy or a girl yeah
it's pretty unique it's interesting I
mean that person looks massive is that
any is that attractive to you at all dad
would you be if if Diane got that diesel
uh no no you're not into that rooting
crackers yes so when you don't when you
don't shift for two weeks and then you
[__] is it like crazy yes it's a lot
like we have to call on the paramedics
all right yeah
what happened
if it happens if you could attack
tomorrow on the plane
oh my god dude what are you gonna do
there's nothing I have to bring it back
here with me I mean it's JetBlue they
don't care
you know yeah really the force it gets
us right out yeah
do you have to like flush every couple
of minutes because it's like a it's a
problem oh yeah I go if I know so I
flush you ever just not flush and then
take a look at what no no what the
amount was no no I don't want to get
nervous yeah it's like a Sharky [__] out
license plates and
why did I eat that I can't figure it out
look at this look at this NYPD robot I
told you did
laughs
yeah it looks like a little bit did I
not say that this is what this this is
what they're doing with making the city
Anarchy is they're going to start to
bring in Ai and robots to to watch us
we're going to be begging it's
Fahrenheit 451 yes Ray Ray Bradbury you
know what is that right no Fahrenheit
911. oh oh well that's the take on it's
a it's one of the required reading types
of books from high school it's like an
old classic the only book I read in high
school was a book called Stoughton
one book one book that we had to
remember
we still graduated so you know he
cheated yeah yeah I'd only run like
literally three or four out of the 50 I
was supposed to read but uh it's about
the future when uh all uh the books and
stuff and and and culture like they're
burned and then robot dog start policing
the streets and uh having books is
illegal it's crazy this is what's gonna
happen
[Laughter]
[Music]
[__] in a while
all right this Saturday Cosmopolitan Las
Vegas Nevada for the love of God please
buy a ticket okay there's 30 of the room
sold people like oh Vegas it's a last
minute Market well it's pretty last
minute buy the tickets I sold 10 000
tickets to New York I got 300 tickets
sold in Vegas what's wrong same goes for
you Kansas City what the [__] do it I'm
there in October the third week of
October at the Uptown Theater and
nobody's buying tickets
yes Georgia for me Georgia May making
Savannah and Athens what are you doing
everyone's out selling you in every
other Market please I love you buy a
[__] dick
christycomedy.com guys tickets for my
special in Chicago on December 2nd went
on sale last week and they sold out uh
on the first day because of you guys I
am so grateful uh that we are going to
add another two shows but that is it I'm
not editing any more than this but this
is the huge announcement right now they
went on sale on Friday
um we are going to do Friday December
1st as well tickets are on sale right
now at
savocanocomedy.com uh they are on sale
you don't even need a promo code I am
not adding more shows after this the
first two sold out immediately so if you
were waiting or thinking about getting
tickets
Friday December 1st those are on sale at
savilecano comedy.com and I will say
because I've been being asked a lot
the contest still stands if you are
going to any of my tapings any of the
four tapings for my uh stand up comedy
special I'm going to choose one ticket
it doesn't matter where you sit and it
doesn't matter what taping you're at I'm
going to choose one person give you a
plus one I'm going to fly you to New
York put you up in a hotel and bring you
on a set of Impractical Jokers I want to
do that as a thank you to you guys
because I couldn't believe it sold out
so fast so you're still in it to win it
if you buy a ticket savocano comedy.com
right now Friday December 1st at the Vic
in Chicago if you have a friend that
lives in Chicago around that area let
them know again I'm going to pick one
person out of those tapings it doesn't
matter where you sit so grab those right
away the rest of the tour is also still
on sale with tons of dates
um as a matter of fact this coming
weekend I will be in uh in October we
have Macon Savannah and Athens Georgia
and even more and more dates all them up
right now on sale at sabalcanocarity.com
they can practical jokers cruise is
January 22nd to the 26th with Eric Andre
with Stevo and we're announcing tons of
more Comedians and bands this coming
week there's only a few cabins left for
that you can go get those at get ship
faced haha cruise.com that's get
shipfacecrews.com check out nopresh.com
noprushnetwork.com for our merch and
savocano comedy.com for my merch I love
you guys thank you so much for your
support I really hope to see you on the
road you good do you eat a lot of fiber
I do actually really what happened today
I could talk about [__] all my my
brother this weekend did a [__] Iron
Man and in the middle of it he had to
[__] and you know it was raining out
he's at Jones Beach he had the [__] he
said it was probably the worst
experience he's ever I think it was
worse than the Iron Man did he [__] well
he had to do a while he jogged or
something no so you got he gets out of
you get out I don't know water and then
he does the bike and then the thing so
he had a he had a dry suit on under
so he goes in and he's like I'm trying
to take the one off without it touching
anything in his face and then get the
second one off and he's like it was one
of those shits what do you say where he
was like the more I wiped the more was
there like he was like I just kept and
he's I keep and he was like dude it was
one of the worst experiences I've ever
had and then there's there's also a line
of like 40 people waiting to get in to
pee and they're like yelling at him and
he's like oh I was in there for like 15
minutes he said it was a dessert and by
the way storming outside wow like he
said it was the worst experience I would
have probably think like people at that
point might just [__] their pants fully
right well so that's a well-known thing
with marathon runners because they can't
give up their Pace or whatever so yeah
like tons of pictures of marathon
runners running which is [__] pulling
out of their short shorts yeah I swear
to God if you could get a quick Google
get your prize
yeah yeah I mean you gotta you gotta
empathize you know because but I don't
because you should have your priorities
straight [__] is more important give
it up yeah give up the time but if
you're if you're doing them like the big
one oh my God the big one it's all I
know because also then but then okay so
what happens you make a good time but
then forever you're that guy yeah
exactly yeah
that picture is that picture exists and
that's full diarrhea what were you doing
I know
stomach indigestion diarrhea
I love that song yeah yeah that's rough
man I I gotta think if it's not the
final like 10 feet yeah I'm probably
gonna just be like all right I'm gonna
go these people know obviously in the
background they know they're not
watching them cheering them on they're
like that guy has diarrhea running down
you know this guy was cool in high
school oh yeah yeah I think everyone
there is like no one's I don't think
anyone's mocking that guy well because
at that point so I think everyone's like
oh my God can you imagine
those two people
the thing is Taylor Swift's in the
carriage the thing is is that if you if
you do that and diarrhea down your leg
you just commit to finish the race then
there's no reason to stop now all right
just go but also what's fun about that
oh my God yeah dude it's it's normally
the diarrhea because that's what you
can't hold that's insane look at this
guy giving him a high five oh that's a
woman
it's not like you're just doing a solid
you know what I mean but the thing about
that is is that that's not coming out in
one shot necessary that's going to
continue to come out yeah so if you're
not stopping you're just running and
continually did you guys ever talk about
that you know the whole like Logan Paul
Dylan Danish [__] with his girlfriend
yeah with all these other girls and [__]
what do you think is worse that or that
like like a sexualized a picture of you
having sex or a picture of you [__] in
your pants yeah like if you're dating a
girl and someone's like yo I got a
picture of her and they flipped the
phone what would you rather see right
right right right
um I would say probably it would be
worse and more shocking for me to see
her with the other guy because every
girlfriend ever have shits on my chest
anyway
you're with has been with people before
you so I mean I would I would rather not
just have my picture on the internet
with brown legs that is yeah that's the
thing it's a guy I know she's bang dudes
before me like that's of course that's
like I can't explain what's going on I
can tell you for sure that my girlfriend
has banged other guys but I don't know
if she's ever taken a [__]
what is this guy just guy walking naked
through Dallas Fort Worth airport you go
you
you by the way yeah
yeah
I was gonna say you go out of that man's
way because you don't want to be in his
purview yeah that's not someone you want
to have a conversation with what's the
reason at least you know he doesn't have
a gun on him or like a [__] bomb or
anything well tell us what might be
inside of them
yeah it's just now do you get arrested
for that of course right indecent yeah
he's rolling up to the gate like group
one yeah he's apprehended mental health
evaluation but then they said it was
fine I let him on the plane
Nation
that's rough too man because you know
like how do you explain that I don't
explain that to like it you know I saw a
guy walking out of the breast pumping
station once in the uh at JFK so I'm
sure he was masturbating in there why
would you walk out of the breast pumping
station what he paid money to go in the
breast pumping station should I pay
money oh yeah oh yeah
100 yeah 100 percent
so I mean so a woman that needs some
pump milk to feed her they would keep
her baby alive has to pay money yeah
it's not just a complimentary milk
decision nothing Ain't Nothing free
Nothing free as my father told me when I
was a young man you'll start to enjoy
life when you understand life isn't fair
did you say that
Proverbs when we were sitting in traffic
on the Verrazano Bridge coming from
Queenstown now my dad would drop gems
wow I don't know if I've ever been given
like that succinct of like these broad
life lessons oh yeah and you you took
that and you applied that you you yeah
you felt that I would be listening to
Hot 97 on the radio with them you know
Martinez Andrew Martinez Funk Master
Flex Angie Martinez uh Miss Jones in the
morning the morning yeah yeah whatever
we do Ed Lover and then my dad would
just drop gems like that and then we'd
stop and go play Lotto what's one that
you can impart on all of us right now
it's nice to be important but it's more
important to be nice
okay there you go all right yes there
you go it's nice and then my mother
always said and then my I would have
that one and then that my mom would
always say you can always I always judge
a person you could always tell
if a person is a good person by the way
they treat people they think they don't
need that's true that's who you look for
and anybody who I've observed in my life
that has treated people that they think
they don't need like a waiter a waitress
or somebody yeah I I keep I get them out
I I would agree wholeheartedly there I
don't know my mom just I don't
know I can't recall any of those right
now I'm sure it's happened but normally
it was just like don't jump you're gonna
crack your head yay
with that thing and I'll tell you I I've
never cracked my head all right so I've
never crack again and nobody's ever
really got their eye poked out I've
asked my friend who's emergency room
doctor said how many eye pokings are you
getting a day with the kids and he said
nothing in 10 years I cracked my head
open did you yeah yeah riding a bike
I've hit a ledge when I was a kid yeah
that's right open yeah yeah I mean oh
correct but it was like it was like I
don't even know what side it's on now
but you can tell one of my eyebrows kind
of does like a little thing they have to
show it back together oh my head is
fully opened up I don't know seven eight
nine like around that time was that like
do you remember obviously you remember
it right yeah you're just in full shock
like you don't even like I remember
being in the emergency room like like
trying to play with other kids and my
dad was like yo chill like you have to
sit here and you can't move because it's
like so insane your whole vision went
black like the last scene of Sopranos
yeah
how many times you've been asked that
question I know we don't holy [__] you
know what's great is I've never watched
the show so like when people ask me
questions about the show I'm always like
I've never seen it and it like gets me
out of everything like you know like
good for you oh it's so like that's half
the reason I didn't watch the show
because I'm like I know down the line
when people are like in episode seven
when you said that I'm like I don't
[__] oh God it's also like I get that
too like where I mean I've never been
anything like that but it's like you
don't watch Impractical Jokers right I
edit it as well so I see it already but
I don't I no I don't watch it I mean
it's if I'm changing and it's come on
there's times I've watched it for a few
minutes but I don't sit there and watch
it or I never watch it when it's on or
anything yeah I I get that I get that
now I don't want myself yeah I get not
one and then you just like you pick
yourself apart so much but that but for
a show as big as Sopranos to not watch I
bet you're probably the only one in the
cast who didn't watch it uh yeah so the
girl played my sister Jamie didn't watch
it until covert and then kovitch she
watched like half of it I think no way
she did what everyone else did yeah
and then I think like she was like oh it
was so easy for me to watch myself as
like a young kid because I gave I cut
myself like gave myself Grace yeah but
then once I was like an adult she was
like I couldn't I had to stop watching
it because so let me ask you too because
the fact that you stopped acting and all
that is very interesting to me because
being in entertainment I don't know how
Sal feels about the sales obviously had
a a different level but I feel like even
me like I like my life where it is now
like this whole idea when you start out
you want to be famous and all that but
then I'm like I don't like that people
know about anything about my life I
don't like I don't want to know what's
at the next level I don't want it's like
all my friends who have seemed to have
the easiest life most fun they're not
the richest they're not the most famous
they're kind of in the middle and
because when you get to that next level
it's like your life gets turned upside
down is that the reason why you're like
I don't want to do this anymore
uh I think
I never wanted to be famous I got into
the business when I was six years old
you know what I mean so it wasn't my
choice like normally when you meet
people who are in this business they
they want that Fame and they want this
because they made the decision to be in
it or I was six years old my dad was
walking with me on the street and some
guy was like oh you know he should be an
actor and that guy's still my manager
today wow like over 30 years he's
incredible like such a great day he was
working at the Old Navy in the queen
I Thought I Loved acting and then when
Sopranos ended and I went to do other
acting I was like oh no I love doing
Sopranos right I don't love acting I
don't like being around these people in
this phoniness I'm like I love
podcasting because we come in here for
an hour you got an hour pot yeah like
Sopranos when we do those dinner scenes
they would take four days yes to shoot a
minute and a half scene yes for three
minutes you know whatever it was just
and you're just like yo we're here again
today eating dumplings at five a.m like
I don't you know you know you're stomach
and [__] it was just yeah that's at
least like you but I want to make it
clear I'm not complaining about acting
it's very it's a dream job it's easy but
it's just like you're like what am I
doing you know and also too like when
people like you know it's it's easy to
glorify like winning an award for a
movie or a TV show but nine times out of
ten you know Leonardo DiCaprio goes and
wins in a war but you have to spend six
months away from his family like in a
place he didn't want to be in and it's
like they they forget that part where
it's like even us even means it's going
on the road for three four days at a
time which I know is nothing to compare
the musician nothing compared to an
actor and they have to go on set but I'm
like I don't want this to be my life I I
I just want to be home I don't want to
always be living out of a suitcase but
it's tough sometimes it's a little
louder because the hacksaws
I know what what do you think they're
using what tool is that is full chain is
that an actual chainsaw
a drill and a jackhammer what are they
doing I don't know fixing the facade
that's literally right outside the
window literally like are you picking
this up on all mics can you tell a
little there's nothing we could do
enough that if you're listening to it
you hear all that the whole time
oh wow all right well maybe we'll pivot
for the I don't know I don't know but
it's not that we can have weeks worth of
drilling
I mean whatever
New York City only in New York only in
New York but so so yeah man so and
you're you've never regretted once not
getting not acting anymore no because I
also think it's something where it's not
like
um you know football where it's like I'm
done and you can't go back like if I
ever want like uh I just did a show for
you I don't know what you could say and
what you can these days everything is so
like crazy but I just did a show for us
agura so you're wrote a show and he's
like yeah you want to do this like read
it whatever so I did that uh for him and
it's like you know what now I'm an actor
again like you know I don't I don't
think I don't think it really is that
kind of job or it's a guy I didn't have
to go to someone and like give my two
week notice or whatever yeah
when do we stop like did you tell did
your agent try to talk you back into it
because oh my God and every non-stop
with the phone calls in this but but uh
so when Sopranos ended I was 22 I told
my manager like don't call me for six
months or like you know however long or
whatever and then I ended up like I was
partying so hard I went to Vegas by
myself for two weeks and I came home a
year and a half later whoa like I was on
one where I was just like I was I was
[__] going for it wow I was really
like out of my mind so uh yeah at that
point he knew like let me we don't want
him to show up you know on an audition
right now I'm sure you've spoken about
this before but you had someone who was
like had someone to reel you in finally
or uh I think you got something wrong
yeah where it was like do I want to die
or do I want to live like do I wanna
because you know like my so my 28th
birthday I took like 35 Molly and I was
up for days days and I was I didn't take
35 like in my hand at a time but like
over the course while I was awake I took
35 and that when I woke up after that I
thought I did like permanent damage I
would never be the same and I remember
being like if I get through this I'm
done what did you feel what was like the
damage after you know when like somebody
adopts like a dog or something and
they're like shaking in the cage and
we're like that's how I was for you know
six days like I was just saying any
noise like I couldn't have done this pod
like you know like a construction like
you're just shivering anytime I would
try and eat something I'd throw up like
I couldn't I would be laying down and
then I would get like try and get up and
then I'd be like oh I need to lay down
again I'd be laying down a bit no I
can't lay down I need to get up but like
at the same time I was also addicted to
Xanax Percocet so it's like I was
probably like you know withdrawing from
some things on other things it was just
like a [__] whole mess so I was like
good for you that you got out of that
man yeah man yeah it's pretty powerful
that and then at 22 having the
wherewithal to tell your agent like I
don't because you would think 22 The
Sopranos was arguably one of the biggest
shows of all time and you're a young kid
you would think like they would give you
movies and whatever but you were like I
don't want that yeah I just did it
powerful there was no like you know
there was something really cool about
Sopranos where it was like we're in New
York and also so it wasn't a kids show
so when I was around kids I was a kid no
one knew who I was like there were no 14
15 16 year olds yo I love Sopranos last
night like 16 year olds didn't have
[__] HBO they didn't watch HBO they
weren't watching soprano so when I was
with kids you had something I was just a
normal dude and then when I was with
adults they were the crazy people like
who were like oh my God like you know
Tony and this and all this [__] so um
and also being in New York it's very
different than like when we would go to
like um award shows and go to La you're
like oh I see how this is very [__]
like everyone's kissing your ass and
like you're something different than
everyone else from New York you're just
like I'm on the train like I'm on the
bus oh [__] like that's cool and then
like go on we're like in LA it's like
people are like oh my God like how do I
get around you like well I'll do and
you're just like whoa like this is
[__] weird it's repulsive yeah so I
just knew like I like when I was filming
Sopranos I was like all I want to do is
be chill with my boys like I just want
to be hanging so as soon as we were done
I was like yo I know exactly what I'm
doing like everybody else was thinking
no yeah just catapult my career did you
know when you first auditioned and got
the part that this is was it already
Rumblings like this show is going to be
huge or you had no idea no not at all
and then so like I told you know I grew
up and I told like my family uh when we
got the show they're like oh my God
we're rich like you know like that was
the thing it was like oh my God you're
on a TV show you go to the Applebee's at
the Queen Center Mall yeah
yes sir yeah belly bombers that'll get
you going oh yeah
honestly some White Castle burgers and
35 Molly should do the trick
murder burgers
so yeah so what so go ahead sorry uh no
so we got you were like your family's
like we're rich my feelings oh my God
we're rich whatever and then we were on
set and the guy who played uh Paulie
Walnuts Tony sirico like rip all right
the greatest the greatest right Bay
Ridge he is who people like what was he
like I'm like you know what he was like
that was him I suppose it was really
that guy in real life like you know 100
yeah he did time everything and he um he
told like I was like yo so we're on TV
show now and he's like oh no he's like
we do this [__] all the time we'll never
see each other again like this is you we
shoot these pilots and then that's it
like you'll never see each other and I
was like oh [__] so now I'm 12 I got to
go back to my family like yeah listen
and then you know however many months go
by where HBO's deciding if they want to
pick it up or whatever and they finally
give us a call like hey you're gonna do
one season and then I remember there was
a billboard in Times Square and people
started calling I was like hey you're in
Times Square on a billboard and we went
to see that billboard and that's like
the last thing I remember of life
four wow you know we're like after like
there was your 9 11. yeah yeah they
don't they don't talk of like uh
they uh you know like Seinfeld talks
like yeah that first season it was kind
of touch and go this like I don't even
remember as soon as it was out it was
just like yo this is I didn't watch
until the third season I went someone
was like you gotta watch you gotta watch
it they threw on I remember I remember
the first line I heard because I became
a fan but it was I I don't think it was
the first episode but it was your line
you came out went no [__] ziti oh
yeah yeah that was the pilot yeah that
was the first episode yeah yeah first
thing I remember and I was like oh my
God and I just like I was like and then
right away yeah and I'd be rolling
around with like 14 year olds like
drinking 40 smoke and then an adult
would see us and be like I don't [__]
see oh my God these kids are like woman
like you know like it was [__] it was
crazy man yeah it's like maintaining a
close relationship with James Gandolfini
too before he died everybody yeah I mean
there was no money there was nobody
where it was like oh that guy this this
person this like it was just like you
know we'd go to the real people like
real people like when we would go to
those Emmys and [__] it's like oh we
don't want to be here but then it's like
oh but we're all together like we'd be
like who are we flying out with and then
you're like in the [__] oh could we have
two cars for us maybe can we share the
car and like you're just it was your
boys like you were hanging out and it
was it was crazy yeah man everybody was
still like we were talking about sharepa
like I'm probably gonna go have dinner
with him while I'm here and Jamie Lynn I
do my podcast with we hang out [__]
constantly like I'm at her place every
Sunday like with her family and this
like yeah we're just you know you fully
live in Austin now I moved to [__]
Austin yeah
am I on Impractical Jokers
[Laughter]
sounds like me write this down
wait sounds like me trying to [__]
[Laughter]
yeah uh I got a [__] podcast like
everybody it's uh called not today pal I
do with Jamie I do it for ymh for uh Tom
Segura and those guys and it's [__]
you know uh yeah good times not in
Austin yeah yeah we're out in Austin
yeah
yeah it's [__] good times it's so
crazy dude thank you so much check out
his podcast
so nice nice to actually finally meet
you
here
[Laughter]
yeah like what are they doing
all right baby there's been hey babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe
hey babe
[Music]